dracula crawley evil morty these aren't
the kind of names that scream doing it
for the greater good they're definitely
villains but in a way they're kind of
right here are even more tv show
villains who did bad stuff for good
reasons
netflix netflix's critically acclaimed
adaptation of konami's castlevania video
game series is a masterclass in
compelling villains every antagonist in
the show is interesting from the power
hungry vampire queen carmilla and the
manipulative necromancer hector to the
severely cynical isaac many of the best
storylines and conflicts in castlevania
come from the dynamics in this rogues
gallery while they each have intriguing
arcs they orbit around the core villain
of the show dracula at the start of the
show dracula is portrayed as a recluse
his centuries upon centuries of murder
and conquest eventually left him aimless
closing the doors of his magical castle
and living a hermit's life that all
changes when a woman from a nearby
village named lisa knocks on his front
door and asks to read through his
libraries of seemingly endless
scientific knowledge she aspires to be a
doctor so she can help the helpless
blown away by her generosity dracula
allows her to stay and eventually falls
in love with her they marry and have a
son together but their familial
happiness is torn asunder when agents of
the church condemn lisa for witchcraft
and burn her at the stake
don't hurt them they don't understand
i believe she's exhausting satan
thus begins dracula's genocidal war
against the human race it's an
indefensible campaign but it starts from
a deeply sympathetic place is dracula
right to want all humans dead no is he
right to believe their institutions
corrupt and their leaders greedy and
violent oh yeah
game of thrones generally isn't the show
to watch if you're looking for
sympathetic villains the series is
littered with the most despicable
characters you can imagine from sadistic
monsters like joffrey baratheon and
ramsay bolton to the supernatural forces
of evil like the night king however some
antagonists in the hbo fantasy saga
deserve the benefit of the doubt and a
lot of them live north of the wall the
wildlings are introduced as savage
lawless renegades who mock the authority
of westeros's great houses and live to
steal and murder there are certainly
some unsavory figures among the wildling
ranks looking at you rattleshirt but
most of them are just ordinary folk
who'd rather live freely than pay
tribute to the continent's arrogant
lords and ladies man's raider the
so-called king beyond the wall is a
level-headed man who does what he
believes is necessary to protect his
people in a brutal place most of his ill
deeds are spurred by his devotion which
given how quickly people can die in
lands of the white walkers is admirable
i don't want people to remember me like
that scorched and screaming
but it's better than betraying
everything i believe the wildlings
desire to avoid the royals of westeros
is also super understandable time and
again the heirs of the great houses
prove that they're far more interested
in hoarding their spoils than protecting
their own citizens manz is a better
leader than most of them and he's honest
about his darkest side too
the whole timeline of avatar the last
airbender is filled with morally grey
characters people who for one reason or
another allow their good beliefs to be
taken too far this is especially true in
the legend of korra in which avatar
korra must constantly weigh equally
questionable sides in different global
conflicts cora's first brush with
villainy comes in the form of amman the
leader of an anti-bending faction called
the equalist they believe that
non-benders have been oppressed for most
of history and deserve equal status with
benders the goal is pure and the
equalists are justified in their
frustrations republic city is run by a
council of representatives from the
bending nations pro-bending athletes are
deified and dangerous street gangs of
benders regularly terrorize ordinary
citizens amman who is revealed to be a
bloodbender in disguise takes things way
too far but some positive effects of the
equalist movement can be seen later in
the series like the public election of a
non-bender president of republic city in
season three korra encounters another
villain who leans just a little too far
to the dark side zaheer a devoted
anarchist zahir believes that most of
the evil in the world is systemic caused
by corrupt leaders and governments his
theory is pretty strongly supported by
how the show paints characters like the
earthqueen and some of the people he
fights are objectively found like amman
zaheer takes his philosophy a little too
far and ultimately falls out of balance
in the show's final season however he
finds some redemption by aiding korra in
her healing process
when the protagonists are criminals and
the antagonists are trying to bring them
to justice titles like hero and villain
can get tricky you wouldn't call hank
schrader of breaking bad a villain any
more than you'd call walter white a hero
sometimes though the lawmen dips just
far enough into questionable territory
that you start rooting for the crime
boss instead that's often the case in
the sopranos particularly when it comes
to fbi chief frank kubitosso qubitoso is
a frequent thorn in the side of tony
soprano undertaking various wiretapping
schemes and other plans to nail the
mafioso once and for all these ploys
often end with collateral damage like
when christopher's longtime partner
adriana was discovered to be a mole and
executed on tony's orders does that kind
of messy operation really make kubitoso
a villain no he was still trying to take
down an objectively evil person and a
dangerous organization and he wasn't the
one who had adriana kill still it's that
kind of gray area that makes qb toso a
perfect example of his arch type from
hank schroeder to frank quitoso to roy
petty and ozark the troubled and
antagonistic agent of the law is a
standard of the crime genre whether
they're heroes villains or somewhere in
the middle is largely left up to the
audience
watching rick and morty you can count on
a lot of rewarding resolutions seemingly
one-off plot lines are often brought
back whole seasons later nothing is ever
forgotten in the adult swim series
leaving endless possibilities for call
backs and long-awaited twists one of the
longest and most important payoffs in
the show follows the plot of evil morty
a morty from an alternate reality who
first appears in season one as the
series progresses evil morty is revealed
to be behind a number of secret plots
that help him to garner great power and
influence over the citadel of rex in the
finale of season 5 evil morty's full
plan is revealed he discovers the
central finite curve an isolated subset
of universes where rick is the smartest
person in the cosmos created by the rix
of the multiverse evil morty explains
that infinite realities exist outside of
the curve in which rick is of little
importance and all that he wants is to
make a way out of the loop he may commit
murder here and there in order to reach
that point but it's hard not to root for
evil morty at least a little bit he grew
sick of being forced into a second
fiddle position by someone else's will
and he did whatever was necessary to
achieve true freedom that's what makes
me evil being sick of him if you've ever
been sick of him you've been evil too
saul goodman or jimmy mcgill depending
on where you are in the better call saul
timeline isn't quite a villain but he
certainly isn't a hero he exists in the
morally dubious zone inhabited by so
many other franchises characters his
brother chuck is a bit of a different
story he's an upstanding lawyer with a
deep respect for societal rules who does
everything in his power to keep his
little brother from succeeding in the
legal field in the context of better
call saul chuck pretty clearly occupies
the antagonist role he presents numerous
blockades to his brother's career path
and is occasionally quite brutal to him
he definitely steps over the line from
caution into cruelty at times yet his
original motivations for these actions
are pretty understandable jimmy spent
much of his life as an untrustworthy con
man making numerous decisions that
eroded his brother's faith in him as a
person since chuck is a respected lawyer
himself it makes sense that jimmy's
shortcuts into the field make him so
angry his doubts are justified and a
good deal of his behavior is as well
still it's hard not to hate chuck he's
far from the most detestable character
in the series but his sympathetic
starting point eventually gives way to
him becoming a proper villain the marvel
cinematic universe's second attempt at a
disney plus series gave us the falcon
and the winter soldier a globetrotting
spy thriller following sam wilson and
bucky barnes the mini-series delivered
some exciting action and a handful of
solid character moments for its two
leads but it was unfortunately dragged
down by a number of riding and pacing
problems complex issues like racial
discrimination social justice and
classism are all broached in the series
but sadly aren't treated with the depth
or deafness they require the falcon in
the winter soldier at least succeeds at
delivering a uniquely sympathetic
villain in carly morgenthau the leader
of the flag smashers labeled as a
terrorist group by international
authorities the flag smashers are a
faction of self-labeled robin hood types
powered up on black market super soldier
serum the group mostly consists of young
adults who experience the men's trauma
in the wake of thanos's snap they
disagree with post-blip political
policies that would leave a lot of
refugees and vulnerable communities out
to drive harley leads a violent campaign
to dissuade the world leaders from
enacting such practices and though she
certainly makes a few bloody mistakes
along the way her motivations are pure
she cares about the downtrodden and is
willing to do whatever it takes to
defend them
but sam what if i'm making the world a
better place that's not a better place
if you're killing people it's just
different
the fire that is the clone wars is lit
by sith lords darth sidious and count
dooku two objectively evil characters
whose primary motivation is the
accumulation of power the conflict they
ignite cast a shadow over the entire
star wars galaxy causing violence for
years on end however most of the people
involved with the separatist cause
aren't sith in fact they don't even know
much about sidious's true plan there are
other irredeemable villains in their
ranks for short but some of those who
take up arms against the republic
actually have good reasons for doing so
take for instance the season 4 episode
of friend anit which follows ahsoka
taono during a series of peace talks
between republic and separatist
representatives on mandalore though
these representatives don't get much
screen time the episode showcases the
regular faces of the separatists leaders
who simply want their planets to be free
from republic rule throughout the series
there are numerous examples of how
everyday galactic citizens have been
forgotten or abandoned by the republic
like the martez sisters in season seven
even the jedi abandoned their old ways
of helping the helpless to serve as
generals in the war that's all to say
that there are plenty of valid reasons
for people to want freedom from the
republic even if the overall separatist
movement is co-opted by the main
villains
the live-action marvel shows that
initially premiered on netflix have been
heralded as some of the comic book
company's best adaptations to date with
series like daredevil jessica jones and
the punisher all getting particular
praise luke cage was another big hit in
the defenders franchise and while mike
coulter did a strong job as the
bulletproof hero the show's most
interesting characters were often its
villains mahershala ali's cornell
cottonmouth stokes is an obvious
standout but he's not the bad guy we're
talking about today instead it's
cornell's cousin mariah stokes dillard
who toes the line between true villain
and sympathetic well-intentioned
antagonist mariah is a complicated
person to say the least as a child she
suffered from constant abuse raised in a
household where violence was a common
occurrence she believes that iron fisted
rule is necessary for neglected
communities like hers because no real
help is ever coming from the outside
world to be fair a good bit of that
belief is based in hard truth ultimately
mariah falls into more villainous habits
but her behavior is shaped by a
traumatic life and an obsession with
accumulating and maintaining strength
she's frequently sympathetic and
sometimes she's just straight up right
netflix's cobra kai introduces a lot of
fresh new characters to the world of the
karate kid adding a multi-generational
flair to the cast of returning stars one
of those newcomers is tori nichols who
quickly becomes one of cobra kai's
sensei john crease's best students and
the sworn rival of daniel larusso's
daughter samantha over the course of the
show sam and tori fight several times
with the latter adopting more and more
aggressive behavior and morally corrupt
tendencies tori is corrupted by the
tainted teachings of john crease but she
also causes plenty of trouble on her own
while her penchant for violence isn't
fully excusable it is complicated by the
nature of tory's life she lives in a
small apartment with her little brother
and her mother who is constantly sick
and therefore unable to work both rely
solely on tori and government checks to
stay fed and healthy she works multiple
jobs to support her family while still
attending high school and she has to
deal with constant harassment from
people like her grimy landlord it's no
wonder then that tory sees sam a
privileged know-it-all from a wealthy
family as a villain worthy of hatred
after all sam is pretty rotten to her
from the start even falsely accusing
tori or thievery simply because she
behaves somehow less than proper
amc's into the badlands is a psychedelic
blend of high-intensity martial arts
action and post-apocalyptic political
drama as you might expect that unique
fusion results in a number of ethically
murky characters as every warrior of the
titular badlands has their own personal
ambitions and motivations one of the
more enigmatic characters in the series
is the master the powerful leader of an
order of warriors dedicated to
controlling the dark powers available to
some humans in the show a handful of
individuals are born with supernatural
powers that activate when they bleed
because these people can be incredibly
violent and uncontrollable in their
activated state the master believes it's
necessary to keep them contained to that
end she sends agents out into the world
to apprehend affected people and
temporarily block their abilities taking
them back to her monastery where they
can be properly trained that all sounds
well and good until you learn that when
the master's guests fail to learn
control she locks them into long-term
comas against their will the master has
good intentions but she acts as the
absolute authority on right and wrong
which ultimately turns her into one of
the series primary villains her methods
are understandable but they're also
undeniably invasive and extreme
netflix's arcane and adaptation of the
popular video game league of legends
takes place in a grim fantasy world
oozing with danger dark magic and
underworld crime the main villain of
season 1 is a man named silco a crime
lord from the undercity near piltover in
times past the undercity was part of a
sovereign nation called zahn but leading
up to the events of arcane it existed as
a sort of lower class subsidiary of the
glamorous pit over silko believed the
land he was born on deserved to be free
once again and he fought in a resistance
movement against the oppressor over time
however sokol lost faith in doing things
the right way and resorted to much more
nefarious means those dark methods
mostly come in the form of shimmer a
dangerous and fiercely addictive drug
manufactured by silcole's head
scientists which transforms humans into
more powerful and monstrous forms he
conceives of the concoction as a means
to claim power over the undercity from
his old friend turned rival vander
ultimately silco's plan is to use his
army of monsters to threaten peltiver
into granting zhan its independence
which nearly works silco was clearly a
deeply corrupted man by the time arcane
season 1 starts but the core motivations
behind his criminal activity are
somewhat defensible in his own twisted
way he deeply cares about the undercity
and the people under his protection like
jinx
i never would have given you to them
not for anything
[Music]
to be fair omar little isn't really a
villain in the y he's an anti-hero at
worst and he's frequently the one the
audience is rooting for thanks to his
campaign against violent drug dealers
and his robin hood persona still omar is
a loose cannon who operates above the
law and undertakes a good deal of his
thievery for personal gain in many ways
the wire is a show about how people are
ultimately shaped by their environment
characters like avon barksdale and
stringer bell do horrible things but
they were raised in a place that taught
them there was no other way it's the
same for frank zabotica who makes tough
calls for the overall good of the people
in his community these characters own
their choices and their mistakes but it
would be a lie to say that they weren't
guided by forces beyond their control
omar is like that too but rather than
buying into some pre-existing system he
chooses to live fully by his own code he
takes what he wants distributes it to
those in need well most of the time and
dishes out his version of justice
without hesitation or debate he's a
criminal sure but he's also fiercely
independent and uncompromising it's hard
to find fault with omar's philosophy or
the way he handles his business even
when that business is bloody morgana
pendragon is dealt a rough hand in bbc's
merlin played exquisitely by katie
mcgrath morgana is the illegitimate
child of uthappendragon she experiences
the opposite of a redemption arc going
from one of merlin's truest allies to
one of his most dangerous foes her
decline from hero to villain is far from
simple however and morgana has good
reason for losing trust in the right
side because she's magical and because
uther believes all magic to be evil
morgana is forced to live in fear of
herself for much of her life she's
compelled to hide lie and run to escape
the harsh repercussions of her own
natural abilities
i just want to be myself
i don't want to be alone anymore she
suffers several challenges as a result
but none worse than her ultimate
betrayal at the hands of merlin himself
merlin attempts to kill morgana because
he believes it's the only way to stop a
dangerous spell unwittingly carried by
her the situation is far from simple but
that doesn't make morgana's full turn
against the agents of camelot any less
understandable morgana slowly becomes
the villain in her own story but the way
she gets there is tragic and the
supposed good guys she eventually sets
herself against do plenty of wrongs
themselves she's the definition of a
sympathetic villain as she was justified
in many of her deeds
the universe of firefly is inspired by
the american wild west which is made
clear in both the show's style and the
behavior of its characters most of the
planets that captain malcolm reynolds
and the crew of serenity land on are in
the far reaches of human settlement and
as such they aren't exactly brimming
with luxury quite to the contrary the
firefly universe is a cutthroat place
where survival comes first and everybody
is working some kind of angle that
doesn't necessarily make them villains
though after all the alternative to
taking advantage of someone is getting
taken advantage of yourself from that
perspective it's hard to see the con
woman saffron as an actual villain sure
she swindles robs and generally
perplexes mal and his crew several times
during the show's brief run but that's
just how she makes her way through the
cosmos unlike some of the other
characters on this list saffron isn't an
extremist who takes her ideology too far
or a troubled person who's pushed to the
side of evil she's just a woman who
plays the hand she's dealt and it's hard
to fault her for doing so
the cw supernatural is rife with witches
demons and creatures of the apocalypse
no matter how you slice it the vast
majority of those characters fall
squarely into the villain category it
would be hard to put the label of hero
on a man whose actual title is king of
hell so we're lucky that mark shepherd's
crowley is just as deliciously evil as
that title sounds from his first
appearance in supernatural crowley
quickly became a highlight of the show's
expansive recurring cast his stark sense
of style and snide demeanor set him
apart from other characters and his role
as an on-again off-again ally to the
winchester brothers put him in a
uniquely fun position in the story it's
all this really necessary
when i've been inside you brother we're
practically family with crowley you
never really know what you're going to
get as he keeps his plans very close to
the chest he's likable and endlessly
entertaining but is that the same thing
as being right look at it this way in
the world of supernatural good and evil
are never quite black and white there
are villains in heaven and heroes in
hell while crowley has done enough bad
in his time to earn himself the villain
moniker he's also just playing the game
he's a complicated person with a
difficult past and he does what's
necessary to stay on top and keep his
world in order
another character whose villain status
is debatable shane walsh of the walking
dead is a far cry from the sadist to
appear later on in the show's run
compared to characters like negan and
the governor shane seems downright
heroic but he also represents the show's
first major instance of humans becoming
bigger antagonists than the undead
themselves yes shane does some
reprehensible things he kills and lies
to protect himself he exhibits
frighteningly violent and possessive
behavior toward the rest of the group
and he's prone to fits of anger that are
usually driven by selfish motivations
and yet considering him in the context
of later walking dead seasons it's hard
not to sympathize with ching he saw the
coming storm in a way that most of the
characters including rick didn't how
would the group have fared against the
likes of negan if shane was still around
would they have been tougher and more
willing to make difficult decisions
would those habits have ended up saving
lives there's no way to know for sure
just as there's no portrait of shane
that's either fully good or fully
terrible it's the grey areas that make
the walking dead so compelling and shane
is a perfect example
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]